you
hello everybody my name is markiplier uh
my name is Mark blur and welcome to
let's play walk a horror chicken game
unlike any other and I know there's been
a lot so let's see proceeded to start
Prezi to start zapping press s to turn
off the screen shaking know how let's
turn it on
alright oh okay alright
I just flip it through channels at night
ah getting the high score all up in here
whoa what the ah my head is bloated
huh what my chicken had exploded why why
was i shopping too fast was I too pro
for this game and you're zapping too
fast
ah what the hell why is this anything
why is this causing this chicken to die
he's just watching DD hey get out here
buddy I'm too proud for you ah
why oh I just got to let my heart rest
huh I don't want to submit my score that
was a poor score right just start
spamming yo GBI yapping in here okay let
my heart cool down a bit until I can use
some nice relaxing castle checkers uh
house on a hill oh hello
dead sock come on was I supposed to do
there am I supposed to do something to
make that not happen but if so I am not
good enough at this game to succeed
let's see mountains circle mare
mountains modern art infinity
ah why what do I need to do to make that
nan a bond there are some instructions
or something
there is no instructions here this is
just just this is total bull everything
about this game is just bull I'm trying
to be here all professional oh I gotta
change the channel when that happens oh
that's right okay duh change it change
it change it okay gimme to pro take it
hahaha I what's to stop you from just
spamming the button so far so good can't
give me I just got to learn to avoid all
the bad channels where's my V chip huh
where's the censorship that I need for
games like this the parents cause this
should really be more concerned and the
rating system is awfully bad if this is
the case get it out of here hi back off
uh-huh can't believe I didn't realize
that you need to die double channel
don't don't no don't don't don't don't
mess with me hi hi
ah damn monsters they're all over the
place
ah oh my head is bloated they came too
quick ah it's a damn shame well I think
this will be a short video because
obviously there's not much more after
this and there is no end so if you want
the most intense horror chicken
simulator that you could possibly or
horror TV simulator that you could
possibly imagine
then give block a try so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see what
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bud
oh you